there is a conspiracy going around that
says all dogs must have new toys
whenever their old toys get old well if
you watch Toy Story you know that that's
a horrible thing just to throw away toys
you remember the last scene in Toy Story
3 you cried I cried you almost cried it
was terrible
toys just getting thrown in the
incinerator them all holding hands like
that there's a recreation cuz I can't
use the real footage it's sad
you bout crying right now just thinking
about it well no we're gonna do
something even worse well you remember
Sid from the first movie well we're
gonna pull a Sid from the first movie in
this market flour mix cuz we're making
dog toys anyway so we're going to be
taking these new fabrics that have been
washed because we care about the dogs
that are going to be using them and also
dogs
[Applause]
[Music]
such a short one hang on yeah dogs
oh please keep it cheeki you remember
this old toys well it's dead no okay
it's dead it's gonna die we're gonna
kill him so we're gonna take these old
toys
we've got new fabrics with yarns
accessories balls we get some babies
over there we're gonna take all these
and we're going to turn them into new
and fascinating new toys Mike sighs yep
cool I don't like that very start in an
hour yeah tiny minutes bear all right I
call picks you
Oh Oh give me a person I call person
[Laughter]
start the clock
someone roughly 10 minutes
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's go yes turned on what be a good
friend yeah I discovered that you don't
call your friends Papa Bear doesn't
weird
you don't know friendship I don't I feel
like I feel like you have a friendship
song that teaches mark about friendship
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
my tours
nice way to god those crazy boys yeah -
wait I've got an idea so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna have like look at the
front someone coming out the ear and a
few coming out a few holes like this
this is some parasitic alien life form
and it's infected this Pikachu and it's
just spilling out the reason why we're
doing this is because I feel like people
to easily just throw away dog toys and
the whole dog toy market is like a
racket they're over so expensive right
and for what like you've right you can
get real plushies for cheaper than
what's going on there like toys for
children are cheaper than toys for dogs
sometimes and I don't know why maybe
just cuz they're built to be tougher egg
I guess that makes sense but I feel like
if you're remaking the toys into
something new you're enhancing your you
could get your kids to do it for you
it's like if your children are working
for you it's not like slave labor
it's like indentured servitude it is you
can get your kids to do whatever you
want them to do that's why people have
kids back in the day people got kids
just so their farm could have workers
for free that's not wrong I'm not I'm
not endorsing anything by saying that
it's just a it's just what's true
what are you laughing at like oh it's
like some horrible worm creature
infected this Pikachu and then like the
pressure from the worms inside the body
exploded the head off of it and send it
rocketing and then this book like main
body of worm came out but it's still
just like it's a conglomeration of many
multiple worms and I think this is gonna
go well because chika and Henry really
loved tassels and they will probably
love to eat worms oh hell yeah oh yeah
you go yeah well you guys both went for
human I do what is that when you corn
you snake
you caught you quarter-cup rui make sure
you make a noise incision this thing
isn't exactly built too sturdy worms
always just slip right outta here what
it's true if you have worms sometimes
and you're on the toilet they'll just
fall out that's a fact
little wider because so this is good
good forcing his eyes apart a little bit
but P fat - there's still some
consciousness in here so Pikachu knows
that it's been taken over and horribly
like turned into some monstrosity of
worms like it's very painful like all
the pain sensors so we're going to
present our toys to each other and then
we're going to present them to the pups
and whichever one the pups play with the
most it'll be like the one they end up
with will be the one they favor and if
they fight over one of them clearly that
was the favorite so we'll call it from
there
so what I've done here is I've created
like a dress that hides the horrible
worm this like the worm has enough of a
consciousness to know that it needs to
hide itself so that it can exist in
plain reality but then you know blowing
I have an idea
Oh sausage yes all right times up hold
on yeah what the timer is up why are you
still going because it's no the timers
are strict fast stead lead all right
it's my goal while seemingly obvious was
to give chica a toy for dealing with her
stress with her master when he decides
to go all loony and be his alternate ego
Wolfer dwarfs - obviously she can easily
tug on the rope
chew on his head share into his torso
and rip apart his pants and of course
what is an alternate ego that you
torture without his little diaper to
make him feel insecure do the mustaches
upside down it is that's great that's
really great mine I wanted to combine
every aspect of a toy that I know my dog
likes the Pikachu dog can only see blue
and yellow so really they're not
distracted by all the horribleness of
this infection even though it's a deep
storyline and that really matters but my
dog loves to pull the fluff out so
there's an ear here intentionally made
so the easy access to fluff there's
tassels so can tug and move around
there's a scarf because I know they love
my sense of fashion there's a scarf and
plaid they love that about
me and also it's addressed to hide up
the horribleness but also you know what
my dogs love most a surprise it's
reversible I just like that it's like do
toys it wow it looks like you tore his
head off and started off with not much
inspiration but I knew no as a belt
buckle my first thing that I wanted was
you know the bass it was very boring and
I noticed that the bass had everything
but ears you've got to be able to hear
when the enemy is coming and so the
enemy being the dogs they're not enemies
but you know that you have to give it a
life you know that's what the dogs love
they love the hunt if you can make it
more realistic the more realistic the
better because they love the hunt so you
gotta give the toy all five senses which
I have we've got sight we've got smell
taste and touch no dogs really love the
furriness of stuff and squeaking us so I
took the tail ripped it open a little
guy inside they can rub and tug all they
want and there's a little belt made out
of a rope which they can also toggle
long as well you have to make sure that
your toys a family friendly so I put a
shirt over it which if they want to
those late dark nights they can tear off
the shirt if need be and he's also got a
little hat that's sewn on top he's got
sight did I mention that he hasn't I see
that I forgot to mention though mine can
scream in pain
all right phase 2 of art anyway what
we're gonna do is we're all gonna throw
our toys over there at the same time
whichever one chica brings back is
obviously the ones you wanted both right
[Music]
to get the toy yes yeah
she tried all three she went back to
each one when she picked that one
I think it's cuz it's not like you
[Laughter]
alright so now that chica has signed we
all agree that's when I see each one as
she did back with one ferus ferus ferus
fear I will say durability though that
hat is pretty much off in the tail let's
judge each other's okay so yours looks
like Walter White and I gotta give you
bonus points
although the noose is a bit of a bold
choice I wanted to put a tassel or a
rope to try and because my dog's back
home loved rope toys I love the fact
that I look over at the very beginning
you're googling how to tie a noose yours
definitely had the most detail yeah like
just then you put a lot most intricate
most aggressive yeah it did fall off but
your ambition was there now you guys got
to give me credit for the reversibility
I that's a pretty cool it's it's pretty
good yeah those are the worm infestation
that's from a real life parasitic worm
that exists it could infect any one of
us make our heads explode off our bodies
and infect us and walk around in our
shell like puppets
is that true yeah it's mostly fruit I
think it only affects beetles but that's
a real thing your infesting your dog
with worms this one
yeah yeah yeah Henry do you want any of
these do we have impartial judges just
for creativity like yours the most
Thanks all right I want someone at home
he's a good artist make hyper-realistic
drawings of each of these toy this is
the horrible worm infested Pikachu on a
sausage head anyway probably leave toys
up to the professionals like us who are
really good at doing this and very
capable thank you all so much for
watching check out Ethan at crank game
one twitch and check out Tyler at
Apocalypto underscore 12
what's the Intuit nut crank crank game
plays yeah everything type in
youtube.com slash crank game and my
channel will come up yeah but that's cuz
I had to remake my channel so I couldn't
use crank gameplays but it redirects if
you do drink game alright yeah well
anyway be sure to put put in the
comments which one was your favorite and
show us your creations on Twitter if you
would like otherwise leave it to the
professionals like Mark said yeah and if
you got other makes you want us to do
write them in the comments we'll do them
in the future thank y'all so much and as
always see you in the next one bye bye